now it's a real honor to be here today
the BCC does hugely important work with
its members very valuable work and it's
a strong respected voice for all of you
at the highest levels of government and
in the media I'm also personally
delighted to be working with an
organization which has such strong
female leadership at the top which is
hugely important as you all know in
today's changing Workforce we need to
harness the talents of all our
colleagues there's a real war for Talent
on at the moment and that has to include
women at all stages of their lives and
careers including raising children and
indeed growing going through the
menopause don't worry any women the
temperature is going to be cool that is
like a prerequisite for me doing any of
these gigs I can rest assured now I also
want to pay tribute to all of you in
this room and the hard work that you and
your colleagues do for this country
businesses of all sizes really are the
lifebloods of our economy and the
Bedrock of our communities providing
jobs opportunities stability livelihoods
and really important services and I
think sometimes in our commentary and in
our politics we forget that point when
politicians talk about the aspirations
they want for a good Society you as
businesses are the only people that can
really help them deliver that and of
course it's been a really really tough
year for you guys businesses have been
on a roller coaster ride you've had to
navigate lock down in the pandemic the
horrific war in Ukraine inflation at a
40-year peak interest rates at a 15-year
high and of course the challenges of
leaving the EU and brexit but despite
this and all the gloomy headlines
businesses have proved resilient last
Friday the ons stats pointed to a 0.1
percent growth again to defying the odds
and avoiding a recession now we all know
that that's not the healthy buoyant
growth that we want but it is a
reassuring sign that businesses are
holding up and if the Figures were
different we'd be in a very different
place now today the BCC has brought
together its UK and international
chamber Network alongside a really
terrific lineup and this of course is
subject close to my heart it's a really
really important time to be gathering in
terms of the political landscape a
really critical juncture we've just had
these fascinating local elections across
England and of course we're now very
much petroling towards the next general
election and we all know that what
happens at The Ballot Box very much
affects what happens in your businesses
and your bottom line it's really
important at this next general election
that your voice is and now is the time
to do it so as well as having top
Business Leaders I'm delighted that
we've got key political figures from the
government and his Majesty's official
opposition here to speak to you and you
know do take the chance to ask them some
questions now the aim today is to focus
on how to channel
a can-do attitude and determination into
building British business now this
conference is going to focus on four key
pillars to do just that skills trade
economic growth and the green Innovation
now they're going to be four breakout
sessions and if you haven't already done
so please sign up to the two which
interests you the most and this leads me
on to a very important bit of admin the
global annual conference app there's
always an app isn't there and hopefully
you won't have to you'll have to think
of a new password but that's the only
thing we ask of you to do now before I
hand over to our first speaker please do
download that app it will give you all
the information you need for the day the
agenda a list of who's here our partners
details more information about the
breakout sessions and most importantly
how you can connect with other people in
the room and if you've got any questions
about the app one of the BCC team will
be at the stand throughout the day and
they can help you with it now it's time
to get going and bring on our first
Speaker we really have got an excellent
but packed day ahead of us now Sarah
Howard has had a long history in the
chamber movement and she's a great
advocate for the power of business for
good Sarah became chair of the British
Chambers of Commerce in 2019 and as a
past president of Suffolk chamber and
she currently sits on the board of the
London chamber now in challenging times
for business she supported the BCC and
the international Network's growth and
she's working with her teams to ensure
that they support the growth and
prosperity of you and your members now
she's got particular interest in skills
development and bringing more diversity
into the boardroom and she's currently
working very closely with neurodiversity
in business Sarah was awarded an MBE in
2015 for her work on skills development
for young people she she's a great
leader and she's a true true champion
for good British business ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome to the stage
Sarah Howard MBE MBE chair of the
British Chambers of Commerce
foreign
[Music]
thank you for such a warm welcome and
thank you for comparing us today it's a
great lineup and who better than you to
knit it together for us
conference guests friends old and new
good morning I'm delighted to welcome
you to our Global annual conference
today
I would like to start by thanking our
partners our headline partner NatWest
will be hearing from their Chief
Operating Officer Solange Chamberlain
later this morning and our supporting
Partners Heathrow and Drax your support
makes this event possible thank you
we are delighted to be joined by the
chance of exchequer believe the
opposition the governor of the bank of
England as well as leading figures from
industry and Beyond and of course it's
brilliant to have so many of you joining
us for what will be a fantastic day
it's good to see so many familiar faces
an exciting to see new ones from our UK
Chambers and Global Network
for those who are joining us for the
first time welcome it's great to have
you with us and I look forward to
meeting you throughout the day
conferences bring people together
but can sometimes miss the value of
having great minds Under One Roof today
with around 500 people here representing
the business Community small medium and
large
our conference is not just about being
spoken at from this stage it's also
about us hearing your ideas and
experiences to help shape the economy
so this year we've shaken things up a
bit we've had limited we've limited the
numbers of keynote speakers
and will have no power discussions
instead we have four breakout sessions
covering skills economic growth green
Innovation and trade
it's your experiences and insights that
we take to government for Change and we
all know that change is needed
I look forward to seeing the outputs
many of you here today are already part
of the chamber Network
and know the benefits it brings to you
whether that is voice business support
or connecting you with businesses
domestically and internationally that
are seeking opportunities or face
similar challenges
I run a business a software company
based in Suffolk and I joined the
chamber back in 2008
so I have personally seen these benefits
as a business owner a member of my local
chamber and even more so as chair of the
British Chambers of Commerce
after my visit to Newport tomorrow to
meet one of our Welsh Chambers I would
have visited Chambers and their members
in each of the four nations this year
as well as meeting with the Irish
Chambers and the t-shock in Dublin and
attending cop 27 in Egypt
no matter where I visit I'm continually
energized by the opportunity to meet and
speak with different businesses wherever
they are whether an international
renowned exporter or a small business
supporting their local community
we are a network created by business for
business building a local National and
international Collective every business
regardless of size sector or location
belongs
I know the BCC team Chambers across the
network and the businesses we interact
with every day are working tirelessly to
achieve our shared goals
these shared goals are clear to me it's
tacking the big challenges of business
where we want government to go further
whether it be lack of skills and the one
million open job vacancies that need to
be filled for businesses to operate at
full capacity
Britain becoming truly Global by
attracting new businesses onto the
Shores from across the world and trading
goods and services with minimum friction
getting the economy back to growth by
ensuring businesses have the right
environment to grow themselves
and of course leading and aspiring to be
a global leader in green innovation
these are the issues we are discussing
today because these are the issues that
come up time and again for British
business and these are the issues we
need to solve together
I could talk all day about our
Collective work on behalf of business
but I think there's nothing better than
hearing direct directly from our Network
so I will leave you with a short video
[Music]
the Chamber of Commerce Network
stretches across the world and at our
core we are all about building British
business
prosperous businesses make for stronger
economies and ultimately thriving
communities
and the Chambers of Commerce are found
at their heart
Our Roots are local our voice is
National and our reach is global
[Music]
we are a unique Network perfectly placed
to connect businesses around the world
our Chambers stretch from Malta to
Malaysia from Ecuador to Estonia we have
connections in over 75 markets globally
people and the world are linked through
business and we know that importing and
exporting is a vital element and a
thriving global economy as Regional
managing director for haze in southern
Europe I know that being a chamber
member gives us access to markets across
the world so as an International Bank
Standard Chartered really values the
good relationship we have with Chambers
across our Global Network
and the British Chamber of Commerce in
Hong Kong is one of the largest
International Chambers and we sit at the
very heart of business in Hong Kong
becoming International chamber of the
year has allowed us to celebrate the
achievements of our members we have a
big mess store this year our chamber
would be 100.
doing in my 30 years here I have
witnessed huge Transformations and
changes for business as the voice of
British business we have strong trusted
connections with UK and international
governments and leaders
our chamber women initiatives supports
and champions inspiring women in
communities across the world
we're helping businesses rise to the
climate Challenge and I'm proud to have
been involved in cop events on the world
stage
Chambers unite for a Greener future
together we drove a global campaign that
unites British Chambers across the world
with the UK's most wide-reaching
business network with accredited
Chambers all over the UK we have a voice
at the highest levels of decision making
we work in partnership with Chambers to
strengthen and grow their local
communities
we have unparalleled reach across the
Nations and the regions of the UK
representing businesses in every sector
from manufacturing to hospitality and
tourism
our mission is to represent UK
businesses their interests and
priorities to the government devolved
Nations and all political parties
The Windsor framework that was signed
earlier this year was a momentous moment
I am Pride that Northern Ireland chamber
was at the center of those discussions
around What mattered to business and in
saying those joint Solutions come
forward
we're so proud to have won UK chamber of
the year which reflects all the support
that we've given to our amazing
membership
our chamber of circular Glasgow network
is now seven years old and has been
helping out members adult circular
strategies as part of their journey to
sustainability
we work with government to drive policy
change to create a Better Business
environment our strategic Partnerships
such as the one with the open University
allows us to harness expertise data and
insights and thought leadership in
priority areas
here at Northwest as the biggest bang
for business in the UK we are proud to
be working with the British Chamber of
Commerce to support British businesses
we have international reach and National
influence
but most importantly we are embedded
within local business communities
at our chamber we work with public and
private sector Academia and Healthcare
Providers we bring these different
groups together to create a flourishing
local economy
we provide practical support to help all
businesses trade and prosper locally
nationally and international here in
Coventry workshop and across England
chamber L ships are transforming the
local skills landscape bringing together
employers training providers and funders
to plan for the workforce skills we need
now and for the future our network is
one of a kind we are truly connected
from our Grassroots up
we are a local National and Global Force
we are the chamber Network
where business belongs
[Applause]
as the British chains of Commerce chair
is my absolute pleasure to introduce our
next speaker
I pointed Siobhan two years ago and it
was clear to me in the interview process
and even more clear to me now that she
is a leader for business being a force
of good and thriving communities
she has built her experience by working
in the big corporate world
running her own business and becoming a
leader leading figure for business in
government
she joined us during lockdown and has
fast become a leading voice of the
network and its members my board and I
share her vision and we have formed a
brilliant partnership
it's time for her to tell you more so
it's one of my greatest pleasure I
introduce the British chains of Commerce
director General Siobhan hagland
[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen I am delighted to
have you here to join us today at the
Curie 2 Center
thank you Sarah for opening our
conference and acknowledging the hard
work of the chamber network over the
past year
as you said it's been a busy one and the
video I think really captures the
breadth and depth of our Collective work
across the regions Nations and
internationally
I would like to extend a warm welcome to
our headline partner NatWest
as well as our supporting Partners
Heathrow and Drax
all of whom share our commitment to the
business community
Community we have been proud to serve
for over 160 years
we at the British Chambers of Commerce
are focus on making the UK the best
place to start and grow a business
building networks supporting companies
and giving them a local and National
voice
because we believe that business belongs
at the heart of our national economy and
the decisions that can energize our
future
its passion drives growth
its potential drives productivity and
its profits Drive prosperity
and when business unites we can harness
its power passion and potential for a
national voice to build our economy and
communities
so
take you back to 1860.
to when the British Chambers of Commerce
was founded
when a group of Business Leaders from 16
Chambers came together and recognized
that while their individual companies
were successful
they could achieve far more collectively
they realized that they needed a strong
voice to improve the conditions for the
business community
this historic event marked the beginning
of a new era in British business
one where entrepreneurs Business Leaders
and governments would work together to
drive growth and prosperity
fast forward to today
and the British Chambers of Commerce
have grown into a powerful and diverse
voice for business
and the UK
our voice is needed now more than ever
with a general election less than 18
months away
we are at a pivotal moment
for the voice of British business
in the last year alone
we have seen eye-watering energy bills
inflation stubbornly remaining over 10
percent
Rising interest rates
and a cripplingly typed labor market
on top of this businesses have had to
adapt to the complex complexities of
trading in a post-brexit Britain
I'm under No Illusion about just how
challenging these times are for anyone
in business
they tell me every day
but let me be upfront and Frank
business needs a fresh relationship with
governments
this is why today
we are launching a national campaign
where business belongs to invite
businesses to that need a voice to join
their chamber
a campaign
that will see business and government
working together in real partnership to
fix our economic challenges
and build an economy that works for all
one that is fit for the future
so
let me tell you a bit about how we do
that now
one of our most powerful tools is our
quarterly economic survey
it contains the views of thousands of
firms
giving us invaluable insights into
businesses of all sizes and sectors
across the country and the issues they
face today
so that when we speak on behalf of our
members to influence government policy
we are doing it in a way that truly
reflects the needs of the business
community
last year we faced significant political
instability and a real lack of solutions
for challenges face by business
we worked hard with our members to come
up with a plan the British Chambers of
Commerce business Manifesto
it set out what government needed to do
to support business
we presented the manifesto to government
and worked with them to implement it
since then these recommendations have
helped set the national agenda
the introduction of vital energy support
to get businesses through the winter
increased investment in child care to
bring parents back into the labor
markets
the reversal of National Insurance
contribution increases
and working with our Northern Ireland
chamber we've played a role in
delivering the Windsor framework
policies that deliver for business
we have the ability to work with
governments and the opposition to shape
vital National policies on the big
economic issues impacting businesses
that's our job
as director General the best part of
this job is traveling the country
meeting the chambers and their members
and they are inspirational
last Easter I saw the power of the
chambers in action when I visited the
Inverness chamber and met the committee
first team
the chamber was working hand in hand
with local organizations to bid for the
first green Freeport in Scotland
the team won the bid
and the Greenport infrastructure will
now deliver a pipeline of renewable
energy projects creating more than 15
000 jobs in the highlands with a further
10 000 jobs across the UK
earlier this year I traveled to the
University of reading to see the
Fantastic work the Thames Valley Chamber
are doing driving inward investment into
the UK creative Industries
the chamber worked in partnership with
the department for business and trade to
support the university to develop a
major film studio and Creative Media
campus shinfield Studios
this will be a state-of-the-art facility
that will not only attract major
Hollywood Productions but create 3 000
new jobs and deliver over half a billion
pounds to the economy every year
and last month
I visited a business called paragraph
at our Cambridgeshire chamber
this is a business that has developed a
microchip made of graphene
it is ten thousand times more conductive
and uses one tenth of the energy of a
normal chip
World beating IP developed by a company
that has chosen to grow and invest right
here in the UK
despite many offers to move abroad
these are just a handful of examples I
could share thousands more
every day we see inspiring examples of
firms defying the odds
using that can do solution orientated
attitudes to push for prosperity
even when they are up against it
I want to take you back to Newcastle
upon time 200 years ago
at that time the boats used to come down
the river time into the city to get
unloaded by the merchants
as the boats got bigger they couldn't
get all the way down the river
so the merchants had to travel out of
town and unload the boats which was of
course costly and inefficient
now
the reason they couldn't get their boats
down the river was because there was a
small rocky island in the center
so the merchants of Newcastle club
together and they put their money in a
pot
and what did they buy with their money
they bought Dynamite
and they blew up the small rocky Islands
so the boats could come all the way down
the time and into the city
they saw a problem they came together
and they fixed it
that is the power of the collective in
action
and today
we all need to work together to make the
UK the best place to start and grow a
business
and we want to grow and scale our
community
whether you are or an entrepreneur with
a great idea who doesn't know how to get
it off the ground
or an international firm looking to
invest in the UK
Chamber of Commerce will help you find
the answer Wherever You Are
as a member of the British Chambers of
Commerce
we are part of your community
and you are part of ours
this means there was always someone to
call and someone will always be there
with the expertise to tackle your
problem
a diverse membership means we can tap
into the minds and experiences of huge
range of members from Tech startups to
Global multinationals
we offer every business
Steady Hand
with credibility on the big challenges
and the convening power to bring
business together to find Solutions
and so
today we are calling on businesses of
all sizes across all sectors to work
with us
to tackle five of the biggest challenges
and opportunities the country is facing
right now
the digital Revolution people at work
green Innovation Global Britain and the
future of our high streets
let me start with the digital Revolution
look at the changes being delivered by
genitive AI
what previously took years is now only
taking days
or even minutes
we need to be ready for the pace of
exponential change
at the chambers we're led by one of
Britain's true digital pioneers
our president Martha Lane Fox has been
at the heart of the digital of digital
innovation
both as an entrepreneur and a policy
shaper
as we move forward into an increasingly
digital age it's vital that we answer
the crucial questions that firms are
asking
how can we use AI to revolutionize the
way we operate
What policies can help us embrace the
benefits
and how can we Safeguard against the
negative consequences and ensure no one
is Left Behind
that's why we urgently need to work in
partnership with government to identify
the solutions
and redesign our future
the Second Challenge is people who work
we have over 1 million vacancies across
our economy 80 of businesses looking to
hire staff are facing real challenges
how are we expected to grow the economy
without a real plan to fill these jobs
we can achieve this through long-term
investment in local skills Improvement
plans already led by the chamber Network
by taking a pragmatic approach to
immigration policy that ensures the
shortage occupation lists reflects the
reality on the ground
and supporting people to get back to
work
third on our agenda is green innovation
as chair of The Advisory Group on
business for the climate change
committee delivering Net Zero is a goal
close to my heart
the UK economy was the first major
economy in the world to legislate for a
binding Target to reach net zero
emissions by 2050.
and businesses must play a leading role
in tackling that shared environmental
ambition
the UK
is ahead of the curve on green
Innovation but with a lack of direction
from government we are seeing the US and
the EU moving fast and becoming more
attractive places for our businesses
this is a huge opportunity for UK PRC
new Global markets for low-carbon
products and services will be worth an
estimated one trillion pounds to the UK
by 2030.
let's not turn our back on that
the fourth challenge centers on
Britain's place in the global economy
post-brexit UK is figuring out its
economic role in the world
both exports and an inward investment
are facing growing competition
but it's a problem we are well placed to
solve
only 10 of UK businesses export
60 of chamber members do
and that is because we know how to find
Opportunities and partners all over the
world and give businesses the tools to
break into new markets
but you're also working to ensure that
UK continues to be a great place to
invest
so that one Global boards are deciding
where to put their money
they see in the UK
the conditions
the talent and the access to finance
that makes it one of the best places in
the world to grow a business
and finally
the fifth challenge we are taking on is
the future of the High Street
a Bellwether of our British towns and
cities the High Street is in a constant
state of flux
the continuing rise of online shopping
altered working patterns and a cost of
living crisis
have hit or places hard
leaving many shops derelict and creating
ghost towns in our communities
we need to bring them back to life
planning business rates and devolution
may not be a conversation starter at a
dinner party
that they are by far the most important
conversations for our Chambers
if we want to revive our towns and
cities we the business Community need to
be a leader in this process of change
not a follower
and shape the future of Britain's
communities
I began
by talking about passion and growth
potential and productivity
products and prosperity
all vital ingredients
and while the UK's presence may look
uncertain
those who doubt us should remember that
it's never a good bet
to bet against Britain
because the history of British business
is a great story
it's the strength of local connections
National influence and Global reach
and the everyday stories
that deliver at extraordinary results
at the British Chambers of Commerce we
exist to give this narrative a voice
because we believe in business
bringing companies together to unite
profits and purpose
driving Prosperity through the power of
the collective
and creating an economy
that works for everyone
at the British Chambers of Commerce
we are where business belongs
[Applause]
thank you
and now for our next speaker
so before turning his hand to politics
he was also a business owner and in 2005
became an MP to Southwest Surrey
since then he has served and led in
numerous departments across government
including Health and Social care the
foreign office
and now the treasury
I have welcomed the constructive
discussions we've had on the challenges
facing business
and know that we have a shared ambition
to maximize economic growth and make the
UK the best place to start and grow
business
and I look forward to continuing on
positive relationships
so
please join me in welcoming the
chancellor of the exchequer Jeremy Hunt
[Music]
yes sound of business down to business
shut sleeves ruled off
um Chancellor it's a great honor to have
you here today we know it's a really
busy time and I think everybody in the
room really really appreciates it and
before we get into some of the more
topical issues one question that I'm
very keen to know from you is what was
it like at the start of of your job
because there you are and going about
your your your business your back bench
business and you get the call from from
Liz truss after the the mini budget what
was that like
it was a bit surreal Aisha I mean I I
thought I was comfortably consigned to
the back benches and obscurity for the
rest of my life and um thoroughly
enjoying myself actually and um I got a
text message saying this is Liz truss
please call and I thought this is going
to be a hoax and uh I was actually on a
weekend away with my wife in Brussels
and um I said I can't believe these
hoaxes who keep uh who keep thinking I'm
going to get caught out and he went down
and had a lovely breakfast downstairs
and finally I was called by a former
special advisor he says no I think this
trust really is trying to get in touch
with you and so I hesitantly call the
number 10 switchboards I think this is a
hoax no no the Prime Minister does want
to speak to you and so it was a rather
uh
surreal moments but um chival mentioned
that I was you know I come from a
business background I set up around my
own business for 14 years and before I
came into politics
and there is no greater privilege for
someone who has been through the hard
graft and setting up a business from
scratch and going through all those
challenges than to be responsible for
our economy and for trying to make life
easier for other people who go on the
same path and so even though there had
been a lot of turmoil after that and
mini budget was it a really easy
decision to make or did you have to sort
of weigh it up because you know there's
a lot to come in and deal with
um there was some immediate decisions
which were difficult but quite obvious
because we had to stabilize the markets
and those are the decisions that we took
in in a few days
um the Autumn statement that followed
was not easy I mean I'm a conservative
and
in order to bring down inflation and to
restore stability we had to cut spending
and increase taxes and those are very
very difficult decisions for any
Chancellor to take
but I think the results of those
difficult decisions is that we are now
on a path where
um not just us but people like the bank
of England and the markets believe we
will bring inflation and interest rates
down and in the end that's the most
important single thing we need to make
sure happens
now that is very much part of the
promises that the Prime Minister has set
out halving inflation this year and
growing the economy but how confident
are you that you can meet those pledges
given that inflation is still quite
stubborn and that growth is sluggish yes
we were not in recession 0.1 but we want
to do better than that well um the
independent forecasters say we will meet
those targets but what I would say is
there is nothing automatic about
bringing down inflation there is a plan
we're going to stick to it the bank of
England has their role through monetary
policy and interest rates we support
them
150 in that but we have our role in
government uh what I do on the fiscal
side in terms of tax and spend has an
influence and if markets judge uh that
we are not getting our borrowing under
control they will punish us with higher
interest rates and so I have a very
important role the government has a very
important role and
you know what I would say to people who
are worried about levels of Taxation is
I agree with that we have to get our
taxes down particularly our business
taxes down
but the worst tax of all is inflation
because inflation is a tax which you get
nothing back for in return but it eats
away consumers confidence means they
spend less on the businesses uh
represented here today and it deters
businesses from investing and so that
has to be the overwhelming priority for
this year
now on taxes you know we know that
particularly for many on your side of
politics a lot of your back benches are
very upset at the the high levels of tax
you know particularly with fiscal drag
more people are being pushed into those
higher tax brackets and it's quite it's
a heavy heavy tax burden at the moment
as we petrol towards the the general
election and if there is any Headroom
are you Keen to try and land some tax
cuts to stimulate the economy either
towards the end of this year or into
next spring
well um we aren't in a position to know
whether we're going to have any Headroom
at all but my priority is to make this
and by the way I completely agree with
with what Chevron said do not bet
against Britain I think we have got
incredible opportunity in this country
to be the most dynamic and Innovative
economy in Europe
and part of that is to have competitive
business taxes and so I made it very
clear in the budget that my priority of
introduced I mean if you look at the two
big challenges facing people in this
room and we've listened very carefully
to what people actually drawn and said
um to expand businesses want to know
that they can recruit the staff they
need so we have an entire budget focused
on labor supply of which child care was
the biggest single measure but those big
measures on for example people with
disabilities who are much more able to
work than they have been in the past
because of the ease of working from home
which is a big change so we've been
thinking a lot about Labor Supply but
the other thing is business investment
and we've introduced full expensing
we're one of only six countries in the
oecd that's the advanced economies 38
countries in total no other major
European country has full expenses that
makes us in tax terms
the most attractive large European
country to invest for Capital and that's
something that everyone is saying really
matters they want us to make it easier
for them to invest and grow their
businesses and and those and that fully
expensive is that something you'd like
to see continued absolutely thesis I
want it to be permanent we've introduced
it for three years
but we made it very clear that that it
is a priority to make it permanent as
soon as we can afford to do so but that
means that you know in this country if
you make an investment this year
in next year's tax bill you reduce the
taxable amount chargeable for
corporation tax by the full 100 of that
capital investment
we have lagged uh France Germany and the
United States in terms of our business
investment
for many years and that feeds through
into our productivity and we need to
increase that and this is one of the
ways that we can support additional
investment by businesses it helps all of
you grow your businesses
and makes it easier to make those
Capital investments in ite plant
Machinery all the things that are going
to make you more efficient in the future
now another thing that um Siobhan
mentioned and I think this is something
that a lot of people in the room uh feel
very strongly about is of course the
skills in in the labor market at the
moment now we're expecting some quite
High immigration figures which are of
course combined legal migration plus
refugees and we don't know the exact
figure but it is expected to be high now
the obr says that much of our growth is
dependent on on migration and lots of
work visas are being issued to help plug
these skills gaps but there's still a
lot of political pushback even from some
members of your cabinet we've seen this
conference as well taking over the last
couple of days many people in your party
and in the cabinet saying no no no we
have got to have lower immigration
figures where do you stand on this you
know many people in this room will say
that we have got to have a migration
coming in to fill those labor gaps or do
you think you should be aiming for much
lower figures
well the the brexit decision uh
whichever side of that debate you were
on was a decision to change our economic
model towards being a high skill uh and
uh high-wage economy and I think that's
something everyone instinctively
supports and it was a decision to move
away from being an economy dependent on
unlimited low-skilled migration
so we've got about a million vacancies
in the economy at the moment according
to the labor Supply figures that came
out yesterday
and we have about seven million adults
of working age who are not in work so
what I was doing in the budget was going
through the four groups of people who
are not in work
um we've just talked about long-term
sick and disabled that's about two and a
half million people around a quarter of
those say they would like to work we
also have a million people who are
unemployed without any sickness or
disability so that group alone could
fill the vacancies then there's 600 000
parents of under fives many of whom have
been prevented from working by high
child care costs budget will reduce
their child care costs by up to 60
percent and then there's the over 50s
some of whom have been pushed into early
retirement by the way the pension Tax
Works and we've put forward a solution
to that so what I'm trying to do is to
make sure that our businesses can find
the labor that they need
in order to make sure that recruitment
isn't a problem
we will at the margins always be
pragmatic so for example we put care
homes on the shortage occupation list
some construction industry sectors and
we will keep talking to all of you about
where there are short-term challenges
but the long-term future is to I mean if
I give you an example if we we have um
about 76
employment rate of our adult population
which is about average for the oecd if
we had the employment levels they have
in Holland we would have 2.7 million
more people in work than we currently do
and Holland has a higher GDP per head
than we have so what we need to do is to
tap into the incredible potential that
we have at home
at the same time as we make that journey
to be sensible and pragmatic about the
immigration requirements where they're
at particular pressures
and the point you make about investing
in the the the workforce that aren't
active at the moment is a really
important one but that definitely will
take time and that involves a lot of
Partnerships with you know Fe colleges
and and the likes to try and move those
people in into work but given that we
know that this debate is very political
at the moment about about immigration
can you send an assurance to to the
members in this room that you will Bang
the Drum for their leads at the cabinet
table even when there are dissenting
voices and say look it is important for
British business to get the skills they
need they can't wait until the 10 15
years they do need those skills now I
don't need to Bang the Drum because the
government is completely United on this
if you look at what's happened since uh
the brexit vote since we left the EU
since we left the single Market the
government has been pragmatic when it
comes to immigration requirements
um but we also want to work with you to
be better at tapping into the potential
that we have at home and to help you
make sure that for example you don't
lose valued employees when they have
young kids and or when you go through
the menopause or indeed that or older
people who who might have a back problem
that prompts an early retirement when
actually they'd rather carry on working
so I think this is a collective effort
to boost or to make sure that we all
remove the barriers to work for people
who want to work
one of the big removals of barriers
which
your home is but again it's the
complicated divisive issue where do you
stand on that
I think it's something that so I'm just
gonna oh yeah
um
I think it's something for businesses
to find their own way through
there are
some very exciting uh opportunities
created by the fact that we've all
learned to use zoom and teams for
meetings actually one example is
childcare so you know it's not now the
case that someone who has a baby needs
to be completely out of contact
UM for a very for for years and years
they have to have their baby on the zoom
call that's the joy of the the zoo and
and we all accept that and it's it's
absolutely fine so it gives lots of
choices if you have a disability it
gives you the chance
and you you have a mobility issue you're
in a wheelchair
um you know a decade ago there was a
presumption that you wouldn't be able to
do lots of jobs which we don't now need
to have on the other hand
um there is nothing like sitting around
a table seeing people face to face
developing team spirit and I worry about
the loss of creativity when people are
permanently working from home and not
having those water cooler moments where
they bounce ideas off each other and not
every great business idea happens in a
structured formal meeting and so I think
um that's why increasingly business is
the same they want people back unless
there's a reason I think we will get to
a point where the default is
uh with the exception of uh specific
categories of work like for example call
center work but I think the default will
be you work in the office unless there's
a good reason not to be in the office
and gradually we're getting there
now let's turn to
um the issue of the the EU and of course
we've recently had this Windsor
um agreement and that's definitely
changed the mood with Britain's
relationship with the
um EU but in every survey that the BCC
has done since brexit these surveys show
that British business is still finding
trade with Europe very very difficult
will you look at new ways that you can
sort out issues like v18 of course the
sort of Thicket of paperwork and and red
tape that many people in this room have
to battle we will always look at ways to
reduce bureaucracy for businesses
um we have now a very solid framework
for our future relations with the EU
that has been settled by The Windsor
framework but more importantly the
Goodwill that that has created and I
think it was a remarkable achievement by
which is sooner to negotiate that
agreement the Goodwill that has created
means possible to have conversations
with the EU about all sorts of issues
that previously we weren't able to do so
we are committed to the trading
Arrangements we have we think we can
make them work what I would say though
is that we want to remain friends with
our neighbors in Europe I think Ukraine
has also changed the mood music and
helped them understand this wasn't the
bitter angry divorce that they feared we
are good Europeans and we will be there
for a fundamental interests of European
security and European values such as
represented by Ukraine but when I look
at Europe what I say is
there is a fantastic opportunity for the
UK
um look up I mean just on the very
narrow issue of brexit we've grown
faster than Germany since the brexit
vote and the IMF forecasts that were
published in Washington last month so
from 20 to 25 they're predicting the UK
will grow faster than France Germany or
Italy so we are absolutely weathering
the change in economic relations
it has been tougher for a lot of people
in this room that has been for a lot of
British businesses of all sizes any
change in your trading relations with
your biggest trading partner presents
challenges and the people in this room
have also had to deal with you know the
energy price uh shock biggest since the
1970s the um
the pandemic it's been a period where
there have been lots of big things that
have been very challenging for
businesses to deal with but the bigger
picture
is that we have an opportunity now to
become Europe Silicon Valley if you look
at the industries that the UK is doing
the best in they are the industries that
are growing the fastest and they're
going to grow the fastest over the next
uh 10 20 years so I'll just give you
some examples because I you know I want
to
reflect some of Siobhan's optimism about
our long-term prospects I know it's been
a very very difficult period but in life
sciences we have become in the last
decade Europe's biggest life science
Industry we provided one of the two big
vaccines in the pandemic the biggest
treatment dexamethasone this country
probably saved more lives across the
globe than any other because of our
science and research technology I
obviously care about this because I was
a tech entrepreneur myself but France
has 36 unicorns Germany 63 we have 144
more than double France and Germany
combined so we are doing extremely well
and micro not Microsoft Google just
announced that they are centering their
Global Research effort on artificial
intelligence in London clean energy uh
second biggest renewable sector in
Europe we now get 40 of our electricity
from Renewables um
we become Europe's largest film and TV
sector over that period we have great
strengths in advanced manufacturing so
I'm not saying let's be absolutely clear
that we are Europe Silicon Valley this
will be hotly fought over but I think if
you look at our track record and what
we've achieved if you look at the fact
that we've got a very strong higher
education sector
very strong financial services sector
this is an opportunity for us and that's
why I think we can be confident that we
will have uh tremendous growth going
forward but it's up to us as every
business person here knows it's up to us
to make the most of that opportunity now
we're just about to go to questions
gonna have some press questions and then
we'll take
from the floor to do ready if you've got
any questions and just one hand over to
the precious one final question for from
me again on the b word brexit a couple
of nights ago that The Godfather the
architect of brexit Nigel farage was on
Newsnight and he said that uh brexit had
been had been a failure what do you say
to that
I think I'm someone who is
free 2016 was on a different side of
that argument to Nigel farage but my
view is that when you make a change like
that
it is up to us it is our choice now um
you know if you look at the changes that
brexit has brought about the one that's
most significant for the people in this
room as an opportunity
is the fact that we have total
regulatory autonomy so there will be
people here who have grumbles and
complaints about The Regulators
responsible for their sectors but we are
able to change the rules
under which our Regulators operate
through Decisions by the UK government
in a way that wasn't possible when we
were in the EU so one small example of
that in life sciences in the budget I
was able to announce that from now on
the mhr ra which is the pandemic showed
itself to be one of the most Nimble
medicines Regulators in the world they
were the first in the world to prove a
covert vaccine
they have decided that they will approve
semi-automatically drugs that have been
approved in America Europe or Japan
and for people who come and get their
drugs approved here we will be the
fastest regulator in the world to prove
so if you want to get drugs to Market
you'll be able to do that more quickly
here than anywhere else that's a really
exciting vision
for people who want to develop new
medicines
and that regulatory autonomy is
something where there's lots more work
to do but there's a really big
opportunity for us to create massive
opportunities for the businesses in this
room excellent that is a brexit benefit
right there now I think we are going to
have um some questions from the media to
start off with and I think we're going
to take our first question from Simon
Jack of the BBC
thank you um Chancellor you'll know that
carmaker stalantis has said it cannot
meet post-brexit rules of origin
requirements due to come in at the
beginning of next year and is preparing
its life for ex for tariffs on its
exports threatening the future of plants
here what can you do about that and
secondly under your predecessor and the
person who hired you the words
industrial strategy were effectively
banned is it time for the UK to have a
clear industrial strategy and when can
businesses expect to see it
uh well let me take uh both of those
questions they're very important we do
have an industrial strategy we've been
very clear about that we've identified
five growth sectors that we think uh we
will need to give special support to
um which I listed earlier but technology
life sciences
clean energy creative Industries and
advanced manufacturing and if you look
at the budget it was squarely focused on
the two biggest issues facing business
today business investment how to boost
that labor Supply and I've been very
clear about our strategy I called it the
four e's education Enterprise employment
and everywhere as being the way that we
are going to make ourselves the most
prosperous Innovative and dynamic
economy in Europe so I think
it's actions not words
I'm very happy to call that an
industrial strategy I'm very happy to
call it a growth plan but what it is
doing is tackling the problems that
British businesses face and one of our
key growth sectors is Automotive which
is a very essential part of the advanced
manufacturing sector It's a Great
British success store story and as we
move to EVS we need to have battery
making capacity in the UK
we have the ability under them Post
brexit Trading arrangements to import EV
batteries from other EU countries but
the reality is there is a supply
shortage everyone is trying to develop
supply of EV batteries and so we need to
have that Supply here in the UK the
closer it's located to
the factories that are making the rest
of the car the better
and all I would say is watch this space
because we are very focused on making
sure the UK gets that EV manufacturing
capacity
and I think we have our next question
from Kitty Prescott of the Times
newspaper
hi Chancellor thanks very much for
taking the question
um you alluded to it just then and
you've repeatedly said that you want to
make the UK a science and technology
superpower by 2030 but I keep hearing
from Tech businesses here in the UK
about their frustration operating here
so revolut uh spoke to me recently about
the irritation and onerous regulation a
crunch in talent and high taxes Siobhan
mentioned paragraph in Her speech
another company a semiconductor business
that's been very vocal about this as
well and then of course we heard from
Microsoft at their president Brad Smith
saying that European Union's a more
attractive place to do business than the
UK
um what do you say to these tech
companies about this these frustrations
and how do you plan to try and keep them
here
um well the first thing is we are not
just Europe's biggest Tech sector but
the third biggest in the world after the
United States and China and it is
absolutely Central to our Ambitions and
I think we demonstrated that when we
stepped in to save Silicon Valley Bank
which was uh London office was looking
after the bank accounts of a number of
very very important Tech and life
science businesses so the first thing I
would say is if you have any concerns
come and talk to me come and talk to
um Kenny bad not come and talk to
Michelle Donlon because we want to do
everything we can to support those
businesses
um
the revolutes case in particular
I have had a number of discussions and
we are introducing a growth Duty for our
financial sector Regulators in the
financial services and markets bill that
is coming up and they have been very
responsive recently in understanding the
lead to Foster the UK's competitiveness
and fintech is one of our great success
stories
um when it comes to Microsoft I mean
there was a merger between two American
companies that the U.S regulator is
seeking to block the UK regulator took
the same view I think one of the reasons
that companies like Microsoft and Google
want to invest in the UK is because we
have independent regulators that aren't
controlled by politicians and therefore
they can be confident there will be a
Level Playing Field I would not want to
undermine that at all but I do think
it's important all our Regulators
understand their wider responsibilities
for economic growth
but for our Tech sector
it isn't just being able to get through
big deals competition really matters and
if we can have the highest levels of
competitive intensity in the end that's
what will make this the most exciting
place in life sciences technology clean
energy all those other sectors
right we now have a tiny bit of time for
a couple of questions from the audience
lady at the front I think we'll have a
roving microphone that will make yeah
absolutely
in front here
and if you just give us uh your name and
where you're from
hello I'm Elizabeth from the Kent
Chamber of Commerce
um in Kent we've recently had
significant
um Financial
um investment withdrawn for the lower
Thames Crossing and other big strategic
infrastructure projects
um how confident are you that all of the
Departments are linked up so that when I
hear all the things you're saying about
business growth but things like that
massively impact there's also been
significant investment in through
leveling up in the port of Dover but
these obviously show that there's a lack
of joined up thinking
um I wonder if you could give your
thoughts on that because it's something
that's a really significant issue for
growth in our area well um
I completely understand that so let me
just say
um the infrastructure investment is
incredibly important and uh in the
Autumn statement I was faced with having
to cut spending by 30 billion and I made
I took the decision not to cut our
capital budget in cash terms but I
wasn't able to deliver the increases
that have been previously planned
um I think that it was the right thing
not to cut our spending because
infrastructure is so important
um and you know as soon as we can afford
to we'll put more into that because
um it's very important for our long-term
productive efficiency that's why we had
to have the delay on the lower tenants
Crossing
um but you know we protected hs2 we
protected core Northern Powerhouse Rail
and that is because
um I mean Kent has got some pockets of
deprivation as well as some areas of
prosperity our vision has to be a vision
which spreads into every corner of the
UK otherwise in the end we're going to
have this imbalance where people feel
they have to move to London and the more
African parts of the southeast and that
is not a sustainable long-term economic
model right we've got time for one more
question uh
lady at the back yeah
thank you nice to see you again
Chancellor it's Miranda Barker from East
Lancashire Chamber of Commerce
as you know we've been supporting an
awful lot of local oven tech companies
in in Lancashire
and we have a really successful
organization called leaner energy who
are making sodium batteries which is the
the better solution following on from
lithium and batteries but we've
supported them with your support with
the university Innovation with innovate
UK grants all the way through the
development of the technology and they
are now about to be attracted Away by
Joe Biden's inflation reduction act what
do we do to keep those Technologies to
make them commercialize here and create
the jobs here how can we work together
to do that
well we have to work together to do that
the inflation reduction Act
is a challenge there's no question about
it but even taking account of the huge
sums of money that the US is investing
in the inflation production act they are
still not investing as much as we are as
a proportion of GDP in clean energy
we've done it through
market-based Solutions rather than
subsidies
but we understand that subsidies have a
wrong and so we are going through a
process now
um I said in the budget that it would
conclude at the very latest by the
Autumn statement
um but we needed to see what the
European response was to Ira before we
concluded our full response but I want
to reassure you that we will make sure
that we remain competitive it's very
important we do we're very proud we've
reduced emissions by more than any other
Advanced economy we are a world leader
in offshore wind we have the largest
offshore wind farm in the world and the
second largest and the third largest so
there are some very big commercial
opportunities batteries hydrogen ccus
these are very strategic sectors for the
UK they will get maximum loss for
support from the government
well ladies and gentlemen that is the
end of our session with our Chancellor
and we're really grateful for the time
you've given up we know how busy you are
you've been incredibly uh generous with
your time so ladies and Gentlemen please
give a warm Round of Applause for Jeremy
okay
now today's conference has been
supported by some of the British
chambers of commerce's key partners and
is headlined by Nat West now before we
go off for are we tea and coffee break
NatWest Chief Operating Officer Solange
Chamberlain is here to tell us about the
brilliant work they do with the BCC and
the breakout session that they will be
leading on economic growth so ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome to the stage
Solange
thank you
[Music]
good morning everyone and thank you very
much Aisha it's a privilege to be with
here here with you for the second year
in a row and to follow the chance alone
on this stage with you all I've been
told I've got five minutes before the
coffee break to discuss building British
business so no pressure and I'll try and
hit as many points as possible
our purpose at NatWest
is to Champion the potential of the
people families and businesses that we
serve at each stage of the journey
whether things are going well or things
are challenging
by the largest bank for business in the
UK I cannot think of a more important
critic Mission critical
thing that we could do to help you and
it also means that our fortunes between
NatWest and knew our customers are
intertwined
I won't go into and revise the
discussions had earlier today around the
current economic environment I think the
best way to sum it up is probably the
word permo crisis
we seem to be experiencing One In A
Hundred Year events at an increasing
speed and I can't think of a time when
business is a phase such a series of
unprecedented crisis and experience a
squeeze on the margin that has not been
seen for over 25 years
businesses first has to survive covid
and again I'd like to thank everyone in
my business but also the collaboration
across people in this room the
government politician Regulators in uh
having had the ability to support
businesses quickly in that pace at this
time but as soon as that was overcome
you then had to face rising cost supply
chain disruptions labor shortages
inflation and higher interest rates
different businesses of different sizes
in different sectors in different
regions have been impacted differently
and it has been great to see the
overalls resilience that there has been
however we're very conscious that more
challenges lie ahead and again I'm very
proud of all the work our colleagues
have done and we've been able to perform
over 700
000 Financial Health checks to make sure
we're there by the side of businesses
and helping foresee what can happen but
we appreciate that it's tough and no
respite
likely to come thin
but time awaits for no one and there are
great opportunities ahead some of our
colleagues did some analysis and we
think there's over 140 billion added
value to the economy by 2030. that
businesses can provide that it equates
to roughly 3.2 million new jobs
however for those businesses to capture
those opportunities rather than for them
to become challenges
they need support to scale grow and
become the best that they can be
and finance and the provision and
availability of Finance is clearly key
to that but it is not sufficient we hear
from businesses and they need support
advice and help to connect in the local
community this is why at NatWest we have
a network of 14 accelerated hubs all
across the UK where we work with
entrepreneurs provide them support and
recently launch a high growth
proposition because we realize the
challenges of not just starting and
having a successful business but really
being able to scale it and I think the
ability for the ecosystem and everyone
to come together all across the various
region has led to many success stories
and as I've said at the beginning
everything to get to those opportunities
is a team Score Sports and it requires
collaboration from the financial sectors
but also from the chambers from industry
from bigger businesses and also from the
government to The Regulators so we can
provide that holistic package to help
you succeed which will mean that UK will
succeed
to take climate as an example a topic
very close to my heart and hopefully we
all agree it is the right thing to do
full stop but it is also a massive
growth opportunity and you heard some
examples referred to earlier
Finance again is key but when you speak
to customers
the customers want to do the right thing
and they want to do the right thing more
and more despite all of the other
challenges but access to knowledge and
data are proving big barriers this is
why 12 months ago again in this room we
launched a tool for everybody whether
you're a customer of NatWest or not free
of charge that helps you from Little
information estimate your footprint and
indicate some action that you can take
again a lot of them are win-win
so I'm sure you all agree given the
audience in this room that those
challenges and the unlocked is the
opportunity won't happen I won't be down
to just a few decision makers in London
it will be driven by the businesses
including the chambers in every region
of the UK which is and again going back
to climate it's amazing when I look at
the stats that actually we see it more
business and startup creation outside of
London than in London over the last 18
months which is again Testament to how
different regions and different
Industries
I am operating more broadly than this
overseas
this is why again our hubs but also
having relationship managers that are
embedded in the community in the
ecosystem who can spend time with you
and support you is something we believe
extremely important even as we're
supported by digital solutions to make
everybody's lives easier
we also launched the SME task force
alongside the BCC and other industry
groups and again we have been launching
that not just in London but across the
region of the UK
I think my five minutes are up so I'll
say thank you very much I look forward
to seeing many of you later today as we
have a panel discussion with some
brilliant attendees
um to talk about building British
businesses and so please do register
it's at 1pm and I hope you enjoy the
networking break
[Applause]
thanks very much
um it's launched out it's very much time
for a little break I was going to say we
break but that sounds a bit too much
information doesn't it so please do go
grab a hot drink from the main room and
do remember to download that app and if
you need any help go and see somebody at
the BCC stand we will start again at 10
45 and we'll be joined by Andrew Bailey
the governor of the bank of England we
will see you then
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
yes
foreign
[Music]
right
now
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
time
so um yeah yeah so I work around as well
oh really
um
today's video
so where are you going today
are you waiting for me
foreign
sometimes
[Music]
welcome back everyone I hope you enjoyed
your break and you're ready for our next
couple of speeches before lunch and we
have some absolutely cracking guests
lined up we're very shortly going to be
hearing from the governor of the bank of
England Andrew Bailey as well as Global
speaker and serial entrepreneur Lindsay
Boyd but first to kick us off I'd like
to give the stage to Emma gilthorpe she
is Chief Operating Officer from Heathrow
now Heathrow is a supporting partner
today and will be leading the session on
the trade Emma's going to tell us all
about the session that they're going to
lead before she introduces Andrew Bailey
ladies and Gentlemen please have a warm
welcome to Emma gilthorpe
thank you
[Music]
hi everyone wow it's wonderful to see
such a full room today and thank you
very much for giving me a brief
opportunity to talk a little bit about
um Heathrow so the theme of today's
conference is building British business
which of course is more important as
ever than ever as we seek to recover
from covid and also through this very
high inflationary period
events like today are absolutely
essential and of course bringing us all
together which we missed so much during
covid to share our learnings and our
Visions but most importantly to help us
achieve our common goal of a prosperous
and sustainable United Kingdom crucial
to this goal and to the successes of
many of your businesses is the
facilitation of trade and tourism across
the country
now my sector Aviation I hope we can all
agree is a Force for good it supports
millions of people's livelihoods it
builds understanding across cultures
connects family and friends and
accelerates global trade
I'm very proud to be although a bit
tired the Chief Operating Officer of
Heathrow now once again Europe's busiest
airport and of course the UK's only hub
airport
that hub airport enables us to connect
the UK's Nations and regions to the rest
of the world and at Heathrow passengers
can access 200 destinations across more
than 80 countries and we're only one of
a handful of international airports to
offer this level of long-haul
connectivity including to emerging
economies in the Brit and the CP TPP
Nations
what also makes us unique is that
Heathrow is the UK's largest port by
value this means that on those 200
routes that we serve we're carrying more
than 180 billion pounds worth of goods
underneath the feet of our passengers
truly connecting British exports to
Global growth that includes
fascinatingly 240 million pounds of
Scottish salmon that is a lot of salmon
you'll hear a bit more about this at our
breakout session later on
but we know that the benefits of
Aviation cannot come at any cost climate
change is an existential threat to us
all and our Collective challenge is to
protect
the benefits of flying in a world
without carbon
the aviation industry can and must
achieve Net Zero by 2050.
that's going to happen through a
combination of sustainable Aviation
fuels developing net zero emissions
Target aircraft and investing in carbon
removal projects there doesn't need to
be a choice between growth in aviation
and protecting our climate we can and
must deliver both
I ought to estimate that sustainable
aviation fuel alone could contribute up
to 65 of the reduction in emissions
required to meet Net Zero by 2050.
the production of saf is a real and
present opportunity for the UK's
industrial policy and economy and has
the potential for wide-scale economic
benefits some say if over 900 million
pounds worth of GBA and nearly 7 000
jobs across the UK
a UK staff Market will boost our
National Fuel security Foster domestic
Supply chains and create new green
skills and we need the government to
legislate for the 2030 staff mandate
which they are on track to do so far but
we also need them to introduce a price
support mechanism that will incentivize
the growth of that industry here in the
UK for British jobs and British
Prosperity but it's not just government
businesses in this room can help too
Heathrow along with many other
businesses as part of King Charles's
sustainable markets initiative and
they've come up with a 30 by 30 proposal
which calls for private sector
businesses to commit to
percent SAS usage by 2030. the 30 by 30
initiatives initiative allows your
business to pledge to the use of staff
for 30 of your business travel
stimulating demand driving down cost and
helping to protect all of the benefits
that Aviation brings
if that's something that your
organization would be interested in
playing a part in and please do speak to
a member of the BCC team and they'll be
able to pass on your contact details I
really do commend that initiative to you
so now on to the real reason why I'm
standing up in front of you today my job
is to introduce your next speaker and
I'm absolutely delighted to be
introducing Andrew Bailey our governor
of the bank of England
Andrew began his career as governor in
March 2020 following a distinguished
career in the financial industry
prior to becoming Governor Andrew served
as CEO of the financial conduct
Authority from July 2016. and our CEO of
the FCA he was also a member of the
Prudential regulation committee the
financial policy committee and served on
the board of the financial conduct
Authority
please put your hands together and
welcome Andrew Bailey
[Music]
well thank you and it's a great pleasure
to be here today to be here at the bcc's
annual conference
and I think the program is a testament
to the vibrancy and Innovative Spirit of
UK businesses
rooted in local communities and I think
that's very encouraging
and I really can't emphasize enough how
important it is to me and my colleagues
to hear from businesses and communities
around the country firsthand
now we all benefit from the data and
surveys of course including the
informative Recruitment and economic
surveys that the BCC conducts
but conversations with people running
businesses and organizations give us the
stories behind the economic data they
help us to connect with what's happening
on the ground in the UK economy and I
can't emphasize enough how valuable that
is to us
and what we find and what I find is that
you know businesses and you all tell us
about the local challenges you're facing
before we see them in the official data
and that helps us hugely
and of course that intelligence has been
particularly vital during the uncertain
times that we've been going through over
the last few years which I'm going to
focus on today
it's also why we have our own extensive
network of Agents Regional agents who
work across 12 or we divide the country
up into 12 regions and nations in this
country
and they spent their time talking to
businesses and local organizations in
all parts of the country
they are our eyes and ears if you like
in local communities across the country
and all of those the rest of us and
those of us who are on the Marshal
policy committee join them regularly
I my commitments and my you know what I
do each year is that I visit each of the
12 regions and Nations at least once a
year so that I can hear directly from
all of you and from businesses as to
what's going on and in fact only
yesterday I was in the southwest uh in
and around Exeter
so whether it's what as as I was
yesterday of part of the time on a
family farm producing cheese in Devon
headquarters of the national supermarket
chain in London a major industrial
production site in the Northeast there's
always something that certainly I can
say I learn from these conversations
whether it's about our understanding of
the labor market and employment the
supply chains the competitive
environment in different parts of the
country all these stories help us to
understand what's going on and I always
say to people when I when I do these
sessions you know
when we're sitting in the Martian policy
committee meetings we do take these that
bring these anecdotes and these stories
directly into the meetings it's quite
common for one of us me or one of the
others to say you know I was hit
somewhere and I was talking to this
business and they said this and it seems
to fit or it doesn't fit with what we're
what we're talking about it really is
invaluable
so I wanted I want to take the
opportunity today to talk about the
current position of the UK economy
drawing on all of that information
and obviously to put that into the
context of the decision we took in the
NPC last last Thursday to increase bank
rate by a further 0.6 by percentage
points to four and a half percent
now I have to start with a very simple
and blank statement inflation of course
is much too high it's our job to bring
it back sustainably to the two percent
Target and that's what we're going to do
but I want to begin by describing the
quite extraordinary situation that we
find ourselves in
it's now over three years since covered
struck and of course changed our lives
in many ways
and the virus first disrupted economic
activity on a vast scale we all remember
it it called for huge public policy
interventions
one's really that few of us I think had
ever thought we would see in our
lifetimes
and then I think in subsequent waves
even as we learn to adapt and benefit
from effective vaccines developed and
frankly record speed
what Kobe did was to continue to
contribute immense uncertainty that is
certainly for outcomes in public health
but actually for the economy as well
and it's striking that after the after
you know a huge sort of drop off a cliff
in the spring of 2020 and quite a quite
an initial recovery as the summer went
on
the level of economic activity measured
by certainly by monthly GDP in this
country has failed to grow Beyond its
pre-pandemic level on a sustained basis
it's still hovering around now the level
that it got to round about in early 2022
and in the latest release in March it it
felt a bit
now that sets the UK apart from other
advanced economies
both the Euro area and actually
especially in the United States have
more than recovered the economic ground
lost during the pandemic
now that slow recovery here
came alongside a series of support big
supply shops that have continued to
shape economic and inflation Dynamics in
this country
I just want to run through them just
very briefly because I think it's
important just
just to lay them out briefly
so the first of these big shocks was a
very sharp rise and rise and the price
of globally traded goods and Global
Supply chains were overwhelmed
by what was it quite persistent and not
really expected shift in demand from
services to Goods across the advanced
economies
but that shock is now considerably
reduced and Global Supply pressures have
eased
now the second Big Supply Shop was
caused by Russia's appalling war on
Ukraine and its people
that had the effect of driving up
wholesale gas prices in European markets
something all of us and we've all
suffered from
and this has been the largest single
contributor to CPI inflation in this
country by some distance
well make him less than 120th of the CPI
basket electricity and gas have directly
added up to three and a half percentage
points to overall Ukraine creation
now Energy prices have now fallen from
their peaks over recent months
and we do expect the effects of this
shop will also now reverse
the third shot that I want to put to
mention is a domestic one
as coveted hits
UK labor Supply growth came to an abrupt
halt
the size of the workforce declined by
more than 130 000 people or nearly half
a percent in the three months from
December 2019 to the three months to
January this year
now the primary cause of that reduction
in labor Supply is an increase in
economic inactivity
not just reflecting the Aging of the
population which I have to slightly say
what's happening anyway but also driven
by fall in the share of working age
people taking part in the labor market
and this has to has contributed to
inflationary pressure
now in the most recent data including
the data released yesterday morning
there are some signs that this shock is
now beginning to reverse
especially amongst younger people
the fourth shock is the one that I think
possibly gets the most attention at the
moment and that is the sharp rise in
food prices
a year ago I did comments that
disruptions to Ukraine's supply of
agricultural products to the global
market could drive up food prices to
worrying levels
since then annual CPI inflation for food
and non-alcoholic beverages in this
country has risen from just under six
percent in March 2022 to just over 19 in
the latest that's March of this year
number
now this is not just a phenomenon in
this country other European countries
have similar food price inflation rates
increases in Energy prices and poor
harvests in addition to Russia's
invasion of Ukraine have played a role
throughout the European continent
these big external shocks continue to
account for a large part of the
inflation overshoot above targets
now there's another effect here because
in worsening the terms on which we trade
with the outside world the rise in
external prices has reduced our real
national income
and this is being felt by households
across the country
and most acutely by those on Lower
incomes
this inflation which is concentrated
more than usually in the essentials of
life
fuel energy food is hurting the least
well-off even harder
because those Staples are a much bigger
share of their consumption
than they are for those who are better
off
and in my visit to Devon yesterday I
went to Citizens advice in Exeter to
meet people who are helping those at the
sharp end of the rise in the cost of
living
it's clear that many people face
difficult choices and have had to cut
back even on Essentials
we know that higher interest rates make
things hard for many people too
but we're conscious that high inflation
always hits the least well off the
hardest
and our job is to make sure inflation is
low and stable
so we have had to raise interest rates
to bring inflation back down
now I'm going to push back against one
argument that you do here which is that
information is high because monetary
policy was too loose in the past
my colleagues Ben Broadbent in Sylvanas
counted that assertion in detail
recently
and the headline I'll say is this
even if we had had the benefit of full
hindsight and the run-up to the war in
Ukraine an ample advanced warning which
for the record of course
nobody did
in order to keep inflation at around two
percent we would have had to raise bank
rate well into double digits
Sunday unemployment much higher than it
is today we would have had to do that in
the middle of the worst pandemic in more
than a century
and the work that Ben and sylvana did
shows if we really could have followed
this course on monetary policy
and let's say then that the subsequent
increase in import price inflation uh
hadn't happened
inflation would have fallen steeply well
into negative territory
and real incomes would have suffered for
lower wages as well as much higher
unemployment
all of that's to say that monetary
policy can't make this impact on real
incomes go away I wish it could but it
can't
what we have to do though is take action
to ensure that inflation Falls as these
external shocks abate
and that the inflationary impulse that
these shops deliver
does not cause persistent domestic
second round of facts in wage and price
price setting that could hold
information up for longer
and that's why we've increased bank rate
by nearly four percent four and a half
percentage points I'm sorry
from December 2021
when it was then 0.1 percent
to the 4.5 that it is now
now in fact you may say this point thank
you for being such a doomster
um so let me say things are looking a
bit brighter than they do a couple of
months ago it's always good for me to
come to come and say that uh we
published our latest Monastery policy
report last uh
week but if I go back to the report we
published in November last year so
exactly six months ago at that time
we expected a shallow but long recession
in the UK
in our latest last week last week's
reports
we're now forecasting modest but
positive growth and a much smaller
increase in unemployment
now
what are the causes of that
well above all improvements in The
Outlaw refracts a very large fall in
wholesale gas prices
and that reverses some of the terms of
trade shot that I was talking about and
have been the primary cause of falling
rail incomes
but alongside that there has also been a
greater resilience in the economy than
we had expected
and we can see that most obviously
in the employment and unemployment
numbers which have been consistently
stronger than we expected
now fiscal policy only had the chance to
come along earlier fiscal policy is also
given at least to the economy
and Global growth has been holding up
better than we thought
particularly in the Euro area and
particularly in China which came through
its ending of zero covid with fewer I
think adverse effects than we we fear
might be the case
now at the same time I'm afraid
inflation has come in higher than
expected
and much of that reflects the food price
story I was just
the latest figure for March 10.1 percent
was 0.8 percentage points higher than we
had expected three months ago at the
time of our February monetary policy
reports
now
we do have very good reasons to expect
inflation to fall sharply over the
coming months
beginning with the April number which
will be released next Wednesday
Energy prices have fallen from their
peaks
and that will start to come through as
lower inflation
to give you a perspective on that
in the marsh release the price of
electricity gas and other fuels was more
than 85 percent higher than a year ago
and that contributes more than three
percent to headline inflation
we expect and this is really
mathematical it's not behavioral that
that contribution will drop
significantly to about one percentage
point in next week's data for April as
those large increases from a year ago
drop out of the calculation
and looking ahead to the end of this
year
if Energy prices evolve as Financial
market prices suggest they will
that contribution from energy will fall
further
and towards the end of this year Energy
prices should begin to pull over all
inflation down
rather than push it up as they have done
over much of the past two years
now we can be less sure about the timing
of Global Food price inflation but we do
believe and all the food producers and
food retailers that I talk to you know
support this story we do expect it to
start to ease too
Global prices of wholesale agricultural
Commodities have come down since spring
of last year
and food producer price indices of East
in recent months too
and the evidence that our agents get
suggests that food producers expect food
production costs to begin to moderate
now this is taking longer than we
previously thought
but we should expect it to feed through
to Consumer and food inflation over the
coming year
and that's the message I can hear when I
go and visit food producers and
retailers around the country
but and I you probably think I would say
this we need to continue to keep a
watchful eye on other components of
consumer prices
what we call Core inflation which
excludes energy and food prices the more
volatile on elements
is driven by items that can have a more
persistent inflationary dynamic
I know the latest number for March at
6.2 percent core inflation remains
elevated
now some of that elevation reflects the
indirect effects of higher energy prices
but it also reflects second round
developments as those external shocks
that we've seen interact with the state
of the domestic economy
and as headline information Falls the
second round of facts are unlikely to go
away as quickly as they appeared
there's an asymmetry in there if you
want
and on the bunch of policy committee we
spend a lot of time on this issue
and we do think that this asymmetry is
important in the inflationary dynamics
that we're experiencing
so we do play a lot of attention to
measures and indicators of inflation
persistence
and those include the tightness of the
labor market wage growth Services price
inflation
now when you sum up all the news that
we've seen on this front recently it's
it's quite mixed really
there are some signs and we saw it
yesterday in the numbers that the labor
market is beginning to loosen a little
there's been some recovery and
participation especially amongst younger
workers
and the number of vacancies that's come
down from the very high levels we were
seeing
the ratio of the number of vacancies to
the number of unemployed which is the
keema a measure of that tiredness has
fallen as a result I should say though
from record levels
record levels of times
our agents report that businesses face
fewer recruitment difficulties that
employees are moving jobs less
frequently
and employers are getting more
applications for job vacancies
but that easing of the tightness is
happening at a slower Pace than we had
expected
and the mark the labor market does
remain very tight
the number of vacancies remain
significantly higher relative to the
number of unemployed than before the
pandemic
and the figures for employment have been
strong
now meanwhile nominal wage growth and
services price inflation have evolved
much as we had been expecting
nominal pay growth has fallen back
slightly
a near-term indicator suggests that pay
growth could ease further later this
year
and that's backed up by what our agents
here on their visits
contacts tend to tell us that pay
supplements have been stable in recent
months and they expect the decline in
inflation of the looser labor market to
begin to reduce pay Awards in the second
half of the year
Services inflation is still elevated
however and the extent to which firms
have already passed through higher costs
will influence the pace at which it
declines
so while as I said we expect CPI
inflation to fall quite sharply as
energy costs begin to ease
though it's a somewhat just in somewhat
slower Pace than we have expected in
February given the particularly the
near-term outlook for food prices
the outlook for information further ad
is more uncertain it does depend on this
exists on the question of persistence in
wage and price setting
now we had a baseline projection in the
report we published last year
conditional on actually what the market
thinks is going to happen to to bank
rate and the market thinks it's going to
Peak at that point before he was going
to pick it around four and three quarter
percent
but in the fourth quarter of this year
we do see some some greater economic
slack opening up
we do see the external pressures
declining and we do think that that will
cause inflation to fall materially below
the two percent Target in the medium
term that was our Baseline View
however there's always a however
we do think that the risks the risk to
that inflation Outlook has skewed
significantly to the upside because of
this risk of Greater persistence
the unwinding of these second round
effects may take longer than it did for
them to emerge
and we are in highly unusual times
yet we don't have a sort of ready
reckoner which says you know how the
economy behaves in these sorts of times
given the shocks that I outlined earlier
and so we have included a material
upside risk to inflation Outlook over
the medium term
and what that means in summary is that
again condition on what the market
thinks is going to have happen to
interest rates in that view of the world
inflation still comes back
to the Target at two percent and stays
around it or just below it in the second
and third years of our forecast in other
words after the first year from now
now let me emphasize very clearly then
this upside risk doesn't actually call
into question as getting back to the
inflation targets but I think it's an
important in a sense assessment of how
we get back there
for him let me just briefly go on a
couple other points
changes in our bank rates appear to have
passed through as would be expected into
new mortgage and corporate borrowing
rates
the pasture into household site deposit
rate has been muted
but rates on term deposits and fixed
rate bonds have risen more in line with
changes in bank rate itself
and I should emphasize that people
should seek out the opportunities that a
competitive market in retail banking
produces
to take advantage of those rates
now in recent months overseas bank
failures have resulted in asset price
volatility and spreads on UK bank's
wholesale funding costs Rose for a while
but it turned out in in this country
that was quite short-lived
we didn't see a lasting impact on
interest rates facing households and
companies
the UK Banker sector remains resilient
it's got robust capital and strong
liquidity positions
but in my view it continues to have the
capacity to support the economy and to
support businesses and households
people shouldn't be able to rely on
their Banks
and that's important for us in setting
monetary policy because it means we
haven't had to aim off in setting
monetary policy because of the situation
in the financial system
and that's an important thing to be in a
position to do
now the changes that we have made in
interest rates are still working their
way through the system
we've seen higher rates quoted on new
mortgages
and while the effective rates on new
mortgage lending have been increasing
the effects of rate on the whole stock
of mortgages is still in the process of
adjusting
the reason for that is that the mortgage
Market has changed substantially in the
last 10 to 20 years there is now a much
larger share of fixed rate mortgages in
this country
so as this process plays out the rises
in bank rate that we're put in place
since December 2021 will weigh more on
the economy there is some more effect to
come through through that and we factor
that in very closely
and that was an important element of the
decision of the discussion informing our
view that we should increase Bank rates
as we did last week to four and a half
percent
so we are continuing to address the risk
of more persistent strength and domestic
price and wage setting as represented by
this upward risk if you like in the
distribution
we will continue to monitor very closely
the indicators of persistence in
inflation and pressures
and we will adjust as we think is
necessary uh Bank rates return inflation
to Target sustainably in the medium term
as our remit tells us we should do
if we saw much greater persistence or
more persistence then we would have to
undertake further tightening in luxury
policy
that's our commitment
we will judge it according to the
evidence thank you
Andrew thank you so much that was a
fascinating
um speech who just gave Lots in there
and we're going to have a question from
the press and two questions from the
audience but before that I mean you know
you've addressed the sort of strategy
behind the interest rates
um Rises I just wanted to ask you if
you're ever worried that there might be
a danger in overshooting now
particularly when inflation is due to
come down which could choke off growth
that is an argument that I do here from
some economists
well it's something that we do have very
actually under we watch very carefully
because we are as I said a few minutes
ago in these completely unprecedented
times yeah we've had this huge run up
obviously inflation you know I set out
the shocks that were going on and I'll
just emphasize this point that one of
the things that we have spent a lot of
time on is this question about you know
will it be symmetrical will it be a will
inflation come down as as we saw it go
up or will it take longer to come down
it will come down by the way and we have
to judge that very carefully and as you
say we have to judge the impact on
activity in the economy and how much
slack there is in the economy and I
think it's you know it's interesting I
mean I mean this is an encouraging story
I should say
um as I said you know
the economy has been more resilient
and particularly the labor market has
been more resilient now I I should say I
see that in many of the discussions I
have with businesses around the country
because people say to me
a lot of people say to me look
I found it so hard to recruit people
that I'm hanging on to them come what
may as it were and that's that's logical
because a lot of people say it's about
you know if I have to make an adjustment
it will be more on the hours worked
rather than on the number of people
because I don't want to go through it
again I want to recruit you know recruit
people once the economy recovers and
that's that's resilience and that's a
good story and we take that into
consideration but just to reassure you
we do spend a lot of time thinking about
the sort of where do you get the right
balance in terms of
and tightnesses
this is immediate question
um I think I'm going to go to Bloomberg
News
yeah hi uh Phil drip from Bloomberg
um just question about the credibility
in Bank of England obviously you miss
the inflation
um shock and now we're raising rates
more aggressively than you'd expected
and your forecast last week reversed a
lot of what you were expecting in
earlier months so you know is there is
the bank's credibility sort of up to the
task
well I feel like I do always make the
point that our forecasts are conditional
they're conditional in the sense of yeah
we have to condition them on you know on
financial market prices we have to
condition them on other policies
and then of course we have to adapt them
for the for the shocks that are going on
around the world around us and as I said
earlier the shops have been huge so we
have to make these adjustments all the
time
um you know I also make the points you
know I was you probably detected quite
strongly pushing back on this idea that
somehow emerging policy caused this
inflation because I'm sorry I just do
not believe that to be the case
so our job and our credibility is to
bring information back to back to Target
and overall you know this is the biggest
test of the of the regime because it's
by far the biggest shock to inflation
but the test for me is that we can have
these things going on in the world
around us which are terrible and have
very bad effects
and the regime can can bring inflation
back to Target that's the test of
credibility for me
right we'll take two questions from the
questions
uh yeah I can see a hand up there so in
the middle of the room
hi there it's uh Matt Ross here uh CEO
of sparknosis uh based in Suffolk we've
businesses facing huge amounts of cost
pressures with energy taxes employment
rates going up most of the uh influence
around inflation is caused by external
factors Global factors
how how do you perceive the fact that
increasing interest rates is another
inflationary pressure that businesses
are having to face is another cost that
we're having to bear and when you talk
about the longevity of
this inflation that's just adding more
pressure and we'll add more longevity
and it puts a huge amount of pressure on
businesses that have got
existing Finance where they're not
perhaps then able to then support from
banking okay
so I do understand the question and I
want to assure you that I do understand
the very difficult consequences of the
of the economic conditions and the
inflation that we're facing what I would
say is this and it some continues from
the previous question that what would be
a worse outcome as if we did not get the
inflation under control when I come back
to this question about persistence and
about second round effects
um it's like consistent with Miles the
previous question I'm afraid there's
nothing that there's no tool that we
have
to make the initial shocks go away
uh and to make this the the effect of
these external shocks particularly on
National real income which obviously
don't feed through into the economy
comes through as inflation go away what
we do have to do is is prevents it
becoming embedded uh that would be a
worse outcome that's why that's why
we're raising interest rates
people
and we've got one final question from
the gentleman at the front here if we
could just get a microphone to this
gentle just a second
thanks a Rob downer from the industry
forum and it may sound like a simplistic
question but is there any point in
having a two percent inflation Target
that you
very rarely ever meet because of other
good factors actually but I mean do you
need more complex mandate or should you
drop the two percent no I think it's
important that we have a simple and
transparent Target when you say rarely
meet I mean actually we did have quite a
long period when we're meeting funny
enough actually the average of inflation
in this country for the decade before
covert it was almost exactly two cents
that's the average of course it doesn't
it moves up and down a bit because
things are always going on
let me say there's two things on it one
yeah the reason we have this target is
the reason we have a Target and we have
price stability is because I think it's
very important for for all of us whether
we're businesses or whether we're
households
that inflation doesn't in its own right
enter into our decisions in a sense we
can sort of say no I could I can I can
you know I can rely on it being stable
why two percent I won't go on at low for
this question
um there is a strong argument for having
a small positive number and the reason
is people say well why don't you say
zero that's obviously price stability
the problem with zero is that because
I've said it does obviously fluctuate
that negative inflation brings its own
problems I mean particularly you know
people then tend to sort of delay taking
it Taking you know economic activity
spending and so on because I think well
the price may be lower
coming that actually can be even worse
so there's a strong logic to having a
small positive number and that's really
when two comes from
and we're just about to wrap up just one
quick question from
me Andrew
um the independence of the bank of
England is something which we consider
really important in our politics but
that was actually thrown into question
over the last sort of you know 12 months
or so what are your thoughts on that
well it's not not from not for me to
comment on politics what I would say I
think is that the some of the actions
that we have had to take and sort of the
other part of our actives is
particularly on the financial sector the
financial stability so what we had to do
last Autumn on the ldi problems how we
had to step in for them they were
relatively small but nothing was
important uh subsidiary here of Silicon
Valley Bank in March I I think it
emphasizes the importance of you know of
our independence that we take these
actions and we take them when we do we
take them rapidly and we have the tools
to do it which is part of our
independence
well ladies and gentlemen that was a
fattening uh discussion and absolutely
brilliant to have Andrew he was
incredibly busy so we're really grateful
for his time a warm Round of Applause
for Andrew Bailey
[Music]
foreign
tastic guest speaker lined up for you
our next speaker is the global serial
entrepreneur Lindsay Boyd like Lindsay
successfully owned and sold two
businesses before the age of just 24 the
second was a very famous renowned
Footwear brand with global distribution
channels across seven different
countries now she sold this company to
Caterpillar and then went home to build
a third business working with and
growing some of the most famous fashion
brands on the High Street she became a
very famous for building the brand
famous Brands 11 years ago she founded
purpose and moved out of the world of
consumer Brands to set up one Earth
which is the first purpose-led platform
connecting Enterprise to trade and
amplifying the voices of communities to
make change she's known as a global
Ambassador for purpose unsustainable
change she aims to help millions of
organizations and their bills businesses
build and scale their good causes she's
a brilliant brilliant speaker please
give a warm welcome to Lindsay Boyd
[Music]
thank you very much for having me here
today thank you to the chambers what an
incredible talk it's been so far hasn't
it
and look I'm not a governor I'm not a
minister I'm not your potential next
president but I am a Serial entrepreneur
I am one of you I am here to speak to
the people and to the businesses and
I've been invited to speak with you
today about the purpose economy green
innovation
and growth with purpose and how we're
all playing into potentially the next
biggest economy the purpose economy for
the next 10 years
now this economy is still in design and
so can hugely the influence
so let's have a look and see who's in
this economy well we talk about ESG many
different people mention ESG smes
businesses like yourselves businesses
that are looking to transition over to
purpose ESG businesses that are already
leading the charge
Charities all CSR programs all
foundations
but the most important
are the people brands the people that
work inside organizations and these
people with voices and they're there for
transformation
so why is the
is the economy even here
it's fair
and technology has been driving
Innovation but we've been going we need
to save the oceans the trees the bees we
need to look at green Innovation and see
how we can get to Net Zero and so the
purpose economy Rose
where did it start
s Henry Ford's assembly line
efficiency
mass production
driven off profit
point A to point B business models the
linear business model
and yet we were driving this efficiency
into transport medicine Finance
Communications and the world's
population
exploded
and so these businesses were building
these linear business models 0.8 point B
I'm not really looking at what came
after point B or was there something
before point a and what happened at the
end of the production line was the end
of the thinking and so by the end of the
20th century what happened was
businesses were efficient they were
making money
but they were damaging the planets
and so the 20th century was all around
profit
how do we deliver food onto shelves and
how do they last longer on these shelves
could we put chemicals into these Foods
so that
they can stay longer and we can make
more money but at the same time isn't
that damaging the planet isn't that
damaging our health
and supply chain breakdowns slave labor
were we using Emerging Markets because
it was low cost and we could just
deliver more and more stuff onto the
planet
fast fashion which was my world where I
came from and fast fashion was the area
when I was you heard 21 years of age and
I manufactured my shoes in career I
spent four years in Asia and I was stood
in the factories of Korea and I learned
about manufacturing I learned about
distribution and we were in the near
business model we didn't think about
what the material was or what was
happening with these shoes we just
shipped the shoes into seven
distributions around the world now I
learned about distribution and I learned
about trade which was incredible at the
age of 24 but we didn't think about what
was happening with the brand
and we were filling up these landfills
we were filling up waste because more
and more products were going out into
the marketplace
and
stick everything
it's funny I I went to Asia and I
realized that they used to wrap
everything in leaves it was incredible
and then all of a sudden for some reason
they switched to plastic and before you
know it there's plastic everywhere
plastic in the oceans plastic on the on
the beaches
so the 20th century was all about profit
[Music]
could be about purpose
and how we build purpose into every
single thing we do and move away from
just being led by the prophet
so
11 years ago
I found purpose
I transferred all my knowledge from the
world of manufacturing I sold my shoes
to Caterpillar at the age of 24 and I
moved into the world of consumer brands
quite excited I had to say because I was
in the fashion industry I mean you know
we got to do something with g-star
Wrangler super dry Lacoste and in the
afternoon I could be in with early stage
growth businesses
and what I recognize what they all
wanted the same thing
they wanted more sales
more awareness
and a bigger value a big evaluation for
the company
and what I recognized was that
that couldn't be it it couldn't be that
we were just in this space of over
consumption where these businesses were
being driven by revenue and profit and
actually being measured the ROI trust me
I work with large Brands everything was
about the ROI the ROI measurement was
all about profit and about Revenue so
what chance did these businesses have if
we were measuring the the results of
these businesses by how much production
they were making and the profit and
revenue you had to keep green Innovation
and green over here sometimes in the CSR
program and businesses would stay
commercially driven
and we've heard from the governments
from the chancellor of the extractive I
thought was incredible by the by this
morning and we've heard from the
governor of the bank of England and we
talk about GDP we talk about gross
domestic product
production over consumption
the measurement of how we're still
measuring in the world today is around
profit
now I'm going to put something out there
what if we changed that measurement
fifth businesses in this room today
thought about a measurement differently
and we looked at a cultural measurement
as well as a commercial measurement we
looked at yes sales awareness value we
all need to make money
and at the same time we look at a
commercial a cultural return which is
how can I drive Legacy into the world
my purpose what's my purpose and how do
I influence the market
Legacy
purpose
influence and you drive a commercial and
cultural Roi what if the government
stood up and decided that the UK was
going to be the first country to be able
to change the measurement for businesses
so that we could have green innovation
in every single business just like we
talk about technology and now technology
is enabling every business what if green
Innovation was enabling every business
and in order to do that businesses need
to realize and be allowed to not have to
drive everything off a profit but be
measured on impact and purpose
so I moved into the world of Enterprise
11 years ago I moved out of the consumer
world and I realized that I needed to
research the market I needed to look at
where was the data and what was
happening with these businesses
so I set up Business Schools and I had
thousands of these businesses come
through these schools we had over a
thousand of them coming in Australia
Canada Singapore Korea I went back to
Korea by the way that was fantastic and
the UK and what I started to learn was
why did they want to drive a business
from purpose what was the green
Innovation that these businesses were
wanting to drive through and how were
these businesses these industries going
to disrupt the market
how were they going to lead this
and I recognized that there were two
types of businesses there was a
commercial business that we've talked
about which was looking at making money
and profit and so forth but they wanted
to know how they wanted to understand
how to switch over to an ethical
business model and they didn't know and
the consumer was starting to look and go
I'm not sure if I want to buy from your
business that you're going to sell to me
at every stage and it's just going to be
about products and benefits
and then there was the other business
which is the cultural business the
charity the foundation the NGO now those
businesses were leading with purpose but
they were spending 90 of their time
having to fundraise and 10 of their time
being allowed to being able to do what
they were supposed to do
so my recognition was
that we needed to help businesses do
both
not be in business and one day become
charitable and also the charity needs to
recognize that they can build an
integrated Revenue system so that they
can drive money into the business and
not have to be doing sponsorship
and both businesses needed to switch
from a linear business model
to a circular business model
and drive it through the end to end of
the whole of the production line that
meant the brand the products tangible
and intangible the channel system the
route to market the sales process the
pricing the packaging the positioning
the whole end to end and then they
needed to look at how could they create
Partnerships with other Industries how
could they trade with each other on
purpose rather than it just being around
a commodity
and so the second thing that I saw when
I did my research was that the human
population gets to a point and they see
so many problems and more and more and
more problems occur that it moves into a
space of a societal shift
and what happens then in order to have a
societal shift is you need leadership
now the first problem was the business
model and the second problem was
leadership
and what I saw was coming from my old
world and look I always broke Trends I
don't know if anybody I am to blame for
the Birkenstocks if anybody does like
wearing them we did break that Trend
um so what we recognize with the trend
space was you had three percent leaders
in a trend cycle that broke a trend
then you had 15
influences that influenced the market
and then you've got 33 of people that
drive it into the mainstream
and so when you're looking at green and
green innovation
what happens and I use some examples
from my old world when the removal of
fur took place you had leaders that were
leading that influences influencing it
and eventually it goes into the
mainstream and there's a societal shift
there's a revolt against people doing
something and before you know it
policy and decision makers and so forth
have to listen to the consumer demand
and this is led by the consumer and no
longer led by the policy makers the
policy makers then have to listen to the
consumer because there's so many of them
the same thing with veganism when
veganism comes into play this last one
was a lady that I got to work with
called Catherine Hamner I don't know if
anybody in the room remembers A lady
called Catherine Hamlet
she was an activist and she was as big
as
um
Vivian Westwood and she was all about no
more fish in the sea 15 years ago and
put a big banner outside selfridges one
of the retail shops in England and she
stood for saving life on Earth this was
15 years ago with slogan t-shirts she
was rare she was an activist she was a
rare person but she was a leader she
went out she was the three percent
Richard Branson Elon Musk these guys
they're three percent leaders then you
have 15 people influenced the market
so the world
has woken up
to purpose
and purpose has driven into the
mainstream
now I thought this was
fascinating it happened in the pandemic
and it kind of went under the radar for
everybody but what I've been watching
was three percent leaders driving this
trend 15
influencers and what happened was
societal shift occurred where people
started waking up to purpose and going
hmm
I'm not sure about that brand anymore do
they
do they are in seeing the supply chain
what are they doing with that brand and
I went to um cop 27 with the BBC and
they asked me to report on green washing
who had been talking about green washing
before and all of a sudden people start
going I'm not sure
your brand I think that's just a
marketing strap line and I think that
you're green washing and I reported on
it for the BBC at cop
and Fair Trade Fair Labor
people were then starting to crawl out
and go
is that really fair trade are you really
paying those people properly and
actually I'm not sure I'm gonna buy from
you and do you have Fair Labor
is that going on could we have a look
and could we see transparency of what's
actually going on inside of your
business
and then they want to know who's leading
things
interestingly who googles people in the
room does anybody Google people
right most people Google people right so
think about the consumer
they're Googling the brands and they're
not only Googling the brands but they're
Googling the people inside the brands
and they want to know what do you stand
for what do you want to be known for
what do the people care about and the
Zed gen I don't know if anybody's got 14
year old kids does anybody I've got a 14
year old boy is anybody got younger kids
right so you will know that your kids
actually they're the ones that teaches
everything these days those kids are the
ones
that are telling us about uh my my son
said to me the other day no mum no I'm
not going to buy that brand because I
don't like what they stand for
and I looked at him and I went like
you're 14 and you don't like what the
brand stands for wow so they want to
know who's leading this and when we talk
about are these kids they don't want to
stay in this business have we thought
because the business doesn't have a
purpose and they're still in the 80s
going my mission and vision is to be the
biggest and the best in the world and
make the most money and these kids are
going no that's not for me that's not my
purpose my purpose is I want to put
school uniforms into developing
countries and you're just polluting the
planet
and they're then going
I think I'll buy from a purpose business
and
I'll buy from that smaller company
that's actually showing me that they're
doing something different and when the
consumer feel feels heard
they'll join you
you will create a movement
all of a sudden you will move from being
a client base
to actually bringing your customer along
for the journey with you because we're
in the emotional connection of the
customer they want to feel heard they
want to they want to come with you and
collaborate with you
so I'm a bit of a trend geek and I
always have them and look and you know I
work with famous consumer Brands so in
order for me to move all these Brands
into future gaps I used to be able to
look at Trends and go where were they
moving to and why were we moving these
into a future Gap
and so interestingly in to 2016 I got up
on stage and said we're going to see
more innovation in society in the next
between 2021 and 2031 than we've seen in
the last 15 years
and I said to people there will be a
crossover point now I don't know what
the crossover point was
but we're now stood in the same
crossover point that we were in 2003.
when social media came on the scene and
we all thought oh that's nice
and now we're in the world of AI
an AI has hit the scene and it's a
crossover point for us and we have
choices
we can go down one route interestingly
my hairdresser chatted with me about it
yesterday and we were saying oh you know
people are worried about their jobs with
AI and what's going to happen because
people are gonna you know people's
skills aren't going to be needed and I
said we
would be behind the AI behind the
robotics
the second choices you can be alongside
it so you can learn about it and see how
it will benefit your business and the
third thing is you can be in front of it
you can lead it
and that means that you can drive the
thing that AI can never do is
re-remember who you are why you're on
this planet what you're here to do in
the world yes it can be the tools it's
very clever you know it'll help you to
understand what you you can give you a
whole script out of different things but
it will never be able to be your purpose
it will never drive you and the purpose
will get you out of bed in the morning
when everything else is failing trust me
I'm an entrepreneur
so these are the key trends that I talk
about from 2021 to 2031 and businesses
Industries societies need to grow with
purpose lead with green Innovation and
Drive Green Innovation into everything
that we do
so the first one is moving from a
faceless organization to one with a face
we need to stop hiding behind the glossy
veneer of this business and recognize
like I said to you people are already
Googling you you're already out there so
what do you want to stand for what do
you want to be known for how do you want
to show up and allow your people inside
the organization to have a voice and
that means allow every single person
when we go inside organizations we'll
have hundreds of them going through
programs understanding what they stand
for so they're empowered to go out and
actually be the channel the distribution
for you and speak on your behalf
moving from competition to collaboration
we've been working with Industries all
around the world and when AI robotics
all these different things come into
play it's never been so important in
history for us to move from a place of
looking at your people and going now
your competition I'm not I'm not going
to work with you you need to move into a
place of recognizing you you were
joining up Supply chains
there is an end to end of the supply
chain not point A to point B anymore not
I manufacture the car and I sell the car
but actually
what's the material where's the waste
who can I distribute with how am I going
to give to the planet what's my business
model and who can you collaborate with
to make that happen
unethical to transparent I talked about
the supply chain and I said that the
consumer's already demanding that they
want to see an ethical transparent
supply chain and blockchain is a really
good example of being able to put that
underneath businesses and showcase what
you're doing with your business and
trust me believe me you will sell more
stuff by doing it
and the next thing I'll say to you is
the consumer is forgiving so if you go
out and go do you know what guys I'm
trying to get my supply chain ethical
why don't we do this together why didn't
you come on the journey with me let me
show you where I'm up to why don't you
help me let's build a competition around
that
and volume data to data for good
the consumer is sick of selling they're
giving you their data
and they're now hijacking their data
they're putting false information into
the computers because they don't want to
give it
so the better form is giving ownership
back to the consumer and saying to them
okay would you like to put your data
with a Cause would what course do you
like is it the bees is it the oceans is
it education is it travel is it who is
it and what you're then able to do is
give the power back to the consumer back
to your customer and give them the
choice and they will then say actually
yes I will give my data and you'll be
able to use it in an ethical way
an interesting not being to campaigning
has been one that I've been talking
about for quite some time and being in
this room today with governments and you
know chancellors and so forth and we'd
all talk about lobbying lobbying is
around
profit and policy campaigning is when
you bring people together movements and
you're able to go out with your client
base and with the consumer and you're
able to make a change together
and then the last one is online escapism
to digital twinning the planet
and this one I find exciting because
we've all moved into a virtual community
it was called Facebook
metaverse that came out and my belief is
that people want to live on and offline
it's no longer that people just want to
be on and digital twinning the planet
means that you will join online yes
but you will be able to build offline
together and that's when you trade
ethically
so in my last section I wanted to
introduce you to one Earth
I moved from a place of consumer and I
recognized that there was going to be
all these purpose businesses around the
world and they were needing to connect
together to unite learn together to grow
and trade together to impact change and
we created a platform that was for
purpose for people to come together and
Unite
so that they were no longer on their own
and they could come and learn in
classrooms learn with other people and
then they could go and trade with each
other to impact change
and I met a man
so we had a number of different
businesses go through the platform
and these businesses came to us and
these are businesses we had thousands of
them that these are businesses that were
typical traditional businesses a travel
agent a pet shop owner an engineer a
beekeeper a doctor an activist and they
all switched over
to be purpose
they all went from I'm a travel agent to
reshaping the future of travel and she
brought over a thousand travel agents
together to join up the supply chain and
was able to Campaign together Rodney
Habib for people that like dogs he came
in as a pet shop owner and is now the
top 100 person on Facebook in the world
and he was all about finding the cure
for cancer in dogs he's in our Canadian
school and rongan Chatterjee I don't
know if any of you know him so he was a
doctor a GP when I met him and he landed
a television program and came in our
school he's now a doctor in the house he
has the top podcast in Europe and he was
all about architecting your health
these are normal people doing
extraordinary things and each one of
them is known
for one thing
leadership
business leader industry leader societal
leader world leader
and then we had Richard year
I don't know where he is today but he's
in here somewhere from the Glasgow
Chambers who came in our London School
in 2018
and he said to me they were running cop
26 and he said we want to connect Global
businesses to trade responsibly with
impact to create a sustainable future
for all
and so he said we we built him a climate
chamber City and the city was supposed
to build an alliance with all the global
Chambers around the world and we started
off with 10 Global Chambers Israel Egypt
Abu Dhabi Indonesia
um obviously England and so forth
Singapore
Zimbabwe and they started to build this
Alliance and what we said was what if we
could get 87 Global Chambers on this and
then what if we can bring the businesses
on and be able to have the chambers be
the conduit between policy and
government and business
and then the businesses come on and
they're able to trade with each other
and create one trade per business and
connect with all the businesses from the
global Chambers around the world
and that was our vision
an integrated Community system where
you're able to drive business industry
society and world and no longer have
industries that are separate from each
other that have them interconnected
together to be able to make the change
so I invite you
to join the quiet Revolution
I invite you to come and build a brand
to shift an industry an impact change in
the world
everything is so beautiful and lovely
and
and Alive you shouldn't say anything
about anything not being
[Music]
what if you could do something different
with your lives that makes a positive
impact on your family your friends
industry even the world
the 21st century is about shifting
Industries towards balance but between
nature and technology and how these two
come together to create Harmony
people have always thrived in
communities living working and trading
together but today living online has
become the norm platforms of Gossip
losing sight of who we are what we are
eager to be light yet for what what if
you could join a quiet Revolution
Connecting People business owners and
world leaders together from first world
and developing countries to impact
Industries and shift the World
[Music]
Imagine your business as a house with
like-minded people living together
connected from the global communities to
the city streets all united through
passion and purpose a brand
where we're building impact in every
single business to be able to make
positive change in the world education
will help children in the way that they
need to learn and not in the way that
Society dictates businesses integrated
into society giving back into their
communities and the World At Large
sustainability is a given and not an
option
[Music]
purpose is the new trading currency
enabling Business Leaders to become
world leaders
we are now all a brand after all do you
want to be known in your industry
outside your industry or even the world
for making a difference
build your brand grow your business
impact an industry shift the world
[Music]
how do you feel foreign